-You play Frank Sheeran...
-Yeah.
-...who they called
"The Irishman."
And you just -- Man,
you go for it in this movie.
A lot of people get hurt
because of you.
But...
[ Laughter ]
But, somehow, you make me love
you and feel for you.
And you're kind of a middleman.
You're kind of stuck in a lot of
situations where you're like,
"Why am I stuck in
the middle of this?
But I'll do it."
And I just --
You made me feel for you.
I went up and down, roller
coaster, and at the end,
there wasn't a dry eye in the
movie theater where I saw it.
Did an amazing thing
and they did a technology
that I'd never seen before --
maybe a little bit in
"Avengers,"
but it wasn't like this.
They reversed-aged you.
-Yes. Yeah.
-How?
-Well, it took
a lot of work to do.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I'm happy, 'cause maybe
it will extend my career
another 30 years.
-Yeah. You're gonna be in movies
for the rest of --
Yeah, even past your life, yeah.
But did they put --
Did you have, like,
dots all over your face
when you're acting?
-We had slight dots.
They didn't want it
to get in our way,
and Marty didn't want that.
I did one other things once,
and we had all kinds of stuff,
but this they did
very subtly and so on.
So, they had references
for little kinds of cameras
taking pictures and a special
camera photographing us.
-I mean, most of the movie,
you're young.
-Yeah, a lot of it -- Yeah.
And then --
-Did they change
your voice, as well?
-No, they didn't.
I mean, I changed it
more toward the end.
-Of course you changed it.
I love it. Yes! Yes!
Yeah! You're like, "Yeah, I'm
gonna show you how to do it."
Yeah. "Watch out, computers."
Yeah, I know what to do. Yeah."
Let me just show you this so
people can see what I'm talking
about.
Here's you as Frank in your 20s.
This is in World War II.
It's not just a photo.
This is a scene.
And it's an amazing scene.
Here's you as Frank in your 40s.
Yeah. And here's you
in your 60s.
And then here's you in your 80s.
I mean, it's unbelievable
what you do.
The nuances to each decade --
I'm telling you --
you are such a great actor.
I don't know if you know that.
-Oh, thanks.
-But, man, oh, man.
What a story.
I mean, is there anything
that you can tell people
about this movie
that if they go like,
"Oh, this is gonna be another
'Goodfellas.'"
It's not really.
-No, it's not.
It was a -- The thing --
It's a very simple story.
It's about loyalty
and a guy stuck in the middle
of two people who totally --
I mean, he had to make a choice.
It was a matter of
survival, actually, for him
to make the choice that he did.
Not to give it away.
-Oh, yeah, of course. Yeah.
-So, it's that simple.
-It's about family, too, and
it's about life and death and --
Oh, my gosh.
And Al Pacino is amazing as
Jimmy Hoffa.
Everybody's great.
Ray Romano is great.
-Ray is great.
-It's just -- I just loved
every single thing.
Even down to the detail, by
the way, of, like --
I don't know if it's CGI,
if it's real,
like, but Scorsese has --
The TV stand that it was on
in the '70s had these brass legs
with these white,
like, Lucite wheels.
-Yeah.
-I had that when
I was growing up.
I'm like, "Oh, my gosh."
Like, I love a movie
that has that much detail.
You guys are gonna flip out.
You have a special treat
for us tonight.
We're gonna debut the trailer,
a brand-new trailer.
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Here is "The Irishman,"
Robert De Niro.
Take a look.
-I'm here to defend you,
so you ever show up late?
-No.
-Do you drink on the job?
-You ever hit anybody?
-I don't think so.
-Alright then.
We don't have
nothing to worry about.
-A friend of ours is having
a little trouble,
a friend at the top.
-He's got a gun!
-Always charge a guy with a gun.
With a knife, you run.
-Big business
and the government.
-We're going to war
with these people.
-Things have gotten out of hand
with our friend.
-I know things
they don't know I know.
-It's gonna happen.
Either way, he's going.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Rated R.
-Let me just say "wow."
Look at everybody say, "Wow."
That's what I'm talking about.
Robert De Niro, everybody.